With a shared movie universe potentially hanging
on every key moment, scene, or battle, Marvel's
movie superheroes are fine-tuned and polished
by dozens of talented artists and producers.
Fans would be surprised to see just how different
- not necessarily better, or worse - the movies
could have been if they had stuck with their
original endings.
Here are Screen Rant's Secret Marvel Movie
Endings You Didn't Know About.
Iron Man 2
The movie may not have been as big a critical
hit as the original, but the final showdown
didn't disappoint, with Iron Man and War Machine
tearing through an army of drones, before
battling Whiplash in his own massive armor.
But the movie almost ended with just a fraction
of that energy.
Originally, Whiplash just took Pepper Potts
hostage, with Tony counting on his friend
Rhodey to blast the villain to pieces.
Pretty anticlimactic, if you ask us.
Ant-Man
You almost couldn't tell that the movie was
created and shaped by different writers and
directors, but there are a few dangling plot
threads - and one is bigger than the others.
When the final fight kicks off, HYDRA Agent
Mitch Carson snags to Yellowjacket tech, and
makes a break for it... never to be seen from
again.
The villain's fate, just like the Ten Ring
nods in deleted scenes, was going to be explored.
But a mid-credits stinger wasn't possible,
with Marvel inserting a scene from Civil War,
instead.
Iron Man 3
The big twist of the movie, that the evil
terrorist mastermind The Mandarin was just
an act, got a mixed reaction from fans.
The critics of Ben Kingsley's 'Trevor Slattery'
would have loved the original ending, which
saw him inject a bit of the Extremis formula
before being blown to pieces in the reaction.
But fans got more of a compromise than they
knew.
When Aldrich Killian reveals that HE was the
true Mandarin, it's actually a re-write.
He originally never spoke the line, which
would have left the Mandarin as a completely
made up character, not an alternate title.
X-Men: The Last Stand
Most fans are happy to just forget the third
entry in the X-Men movie series, but its closing
scenes actually did help end the instalment
on a happier note.
Not only does Rogue return to the Xavier School
- with her powers returned -
but the school itself welcomes more mutant
children than ever before - meaning a whole
new crop of X-Men to choose from.
Thor
The god of thunder had no choice but to destroy
the Bifrost to save the day, which meant he
couldn't return to Earth, or his new girlfriend.
The original ending actually seemed to hint
at a solution, with Jane Foster developing
a beacon to help Thor find his way back.
Not to mention Dr. Erik Selvig dropping a
reference to S.W.O.R.D., another division
of the ultra covert S.H.I.E.L.D. agency.
The Avengers: Age of Ultron
Marvel's hero team made sure to save each
and every innocent bystander from Ultron's
attack, guaranteeing Marvel wouldn't get slammed
with the same criticism over collateral damage
that Man of Steel had to deal with.
But one Avengers didn't make it out alive:
Quicksilver.
But that wasn't always the case.
Fans of the speedster may be happier, or more
disappointed to hear that Joss Whedon originally
planned to have him return safe and sound
in the final shot of Cap's New Avengers.
But deciding that it undercut the actual cost
of the story, decided against it.
The Wolverine
It's hard to believe: over a decade and a
half of Wolverine appearing as Fox's biggest
superhero star, and he still hasn't worn anything
close to his iconic comic costume.
We couldn't leave the scene that solved that
problem off our list, since the hero's second
solo movie was going to end with Logan receiving
the yellow mask and suit as a gift.
For some reason, the scene was cut, leaving
fans to wonder if Wolverine's next movie role
will finally deliver - just as they always
have.
The Amazing Spider-Man 2
The first Spider-Man reboot earned some enemies
when it promised to tell "the untold story"
of Peter Parker's origins, and then didn't
in any real way.
But the sequel actually planned to double
down on dividing fans, with Peter's father
returning from the dead, having spent Peter's
life in hiding, not in a grave.
It was a massive change to the hero's nature,
but with the scene deleted and the movie leading
to a brand new reboot, it's probably better
off left on the cutting room floor.
The Amazing Spider-Man 2
Since the movie's final act was dominated
by the death of Gwen Stacy, fans probably
forgot that Peter's actual fight with the
villain, Green Goblin, was pretty anti-climactic.
Goblin is knocked unconscious, and that's
that.
In the original version, Gwen's death was
met with maniacal laughter from the villain,
sending Peter into a rage, beating his former
friend to within inches of his life.
It was probably seen as a little too dark
for the film, and cut out completely.
Guardians of the Galaxy
The tears were flowing when Peter Quill read
his mother's final letter, but the actual
ending of Guardians of the Galaxy kept the
sadness going even longer.
Aside from confirming that the villain Nebula
was alive and angry, the final scene returned
to Earth, showing Peter's grandfather from
the start of the movie looking to the stars.
He apparently saw Peter get abducted into
space, and was waiting, hoping he would eventually
return as a grown man.
Director James Gunn admitted it was beautiful,
but too sad a note to end the story on.
Those are the alternate endings and original
conclusions to some of Marvel's biggest movies,
but which ones are your favorite?
Let us know and don't forget to subscribe
to our channel for more videos like this one.